I'm still a dude you're still a dude
we're all still dudes so strap into the
burger mobile and get ready for
everything you need to know about the
long awaited sequel to Good Burger
longtime Nickelodeon fans have been
holding out a long time to hear those
magical words one more time you know the
ones welcome to Good Burger home of the
Good Burger can I take you order the
original Good Burger movie was released
all the way back in July 1997 and it
went on to gross a little more than $23
million at the box office it was based
on a fan favorite sketch on
Nickelodeon's all that that was popular
enough to convince exec to give Ed
Dexter and their co-workers a chance at
the big screen big time now the eagerly
anticipated sequel is slated to arrive
on Paramount Plus on November 22nd 2023
that's looking like a pretty huge day
for Cinema as Napoleon Maestro and wish
are all set to hit theaters on that same
date but if you're not in the mood for
dramatic biopics or animated adventures
then you can certainly stay home and
have a fantastic evening by streaming
Good Burger 2 instead if you're curious
about what Ed and Dexter are up to all
these years later the official log line
gives a hint of what's to come the movie
follows Dexter Reed and original cashier
Ed is a reunite in the present day at
fast food restaurant Goodburger with a
hilarious new group of employees and an
earlier paramont press release for March
2023 went into a little more detail by
revealing Dexter Reed is down on his
luck after another one of his inventions
fails Ed welcomes Dex back to Goodburger
with open arms and gives him his old job
back with a new crew working at
Goodburger Dex devises a plan to get
back on his feet but unfortunately puts
the fate of good burger at risk once
again the Good Burger 2 trailer also
shows that Ed Dexter and the rest of the
staff are going to end up fired as part
of a plan by the evil corporate
executive who runs good Burger's parent
company her ultimate plan is to open
outlets around the world that are
staffed entirely by robots with this
delightfully fun premise we're hoping
that the movie will serve up plenty of
goofy comedy a dose of '90s nostalgia
and perhaps a few tugs at the
heartstrings The New Adventures of AD
andex Starts Now for a lot of fans the
most important thing to know about
Goodburger 2 is that Kenyan Thompson and
Kell Mitchell are returning to play
Dexter net it's impossible to imagine
anything good Burger related without
them after all and they'll be joined by
an ensemble of some new and returning
faces L re Howry will play Cecil mcnean
who's described in the paramont press
release as a lawyer for the corporation
Mega Corp Julian Bell will play Mega
Corp CEO C Boswell while Kamaya Fairburn
has been cast as Mia who's described as
a cool and competent teen who works at
Goodburger to help her mother when she
can and perhaps most intriguingly of all
Alex R Hibbert is set to play Ed 2 who's
a mini me version of his dad Ed and good
Burger's newest trainee and Keenan and
Kell won't be the all that alums
returning as Josh server and Lorie Beth
Denberg will reprise their roles as Fizz
and Connie moldun respectively perhaps
most significantly Carmen Electra is
also returning to play the part of rock
sand from the original Goodburger on top
of all that there will be a slew of
celebrity cameos and brief appearances
by the likes of Al Rooker Nicole berer
Lua Borg and Rob
gronowski it takes more than a bun and
some beef to make a hamburger and it
takes more than just a cast of actors to
produce Good Burger 2 with that in mind
sitting in the director's chair for the
second installment is is Phil Trail this
is his first big screen feature since
2011's Chalet girl who was worked
steadily on TV in the meantime on a
variety of popular sitcoms meanwhile
Kevin Kobo and Heth seert who wrote the
original good burger have also penned
the script with additional material from
James III Kobo and seert are also
serving as executive producers however
one writer who won't be returning from
the original is Dan Schneider The
Mastermind behind various iconic
Nickelodeon shows after allegations of
misconduct against Schneider were made
public in 2018 he was dropped by the
network and went on a multi-year
Hiatus back in 1997 the original good
burger was given a PG rating due to a
few coarse words and some sexual
innuendo so it shouldn't be too
surprising that the sequel hasn't been
slapped with a hard r instead since it's
coming to streaming instead of theaters
it's been rated at TV PG which means you
can probably expect the same kind of
mildly objectionable content as the
first film do you think you can get me
to a hospital I think I broke my ass
perhaps a few jokes will be a tad edgier
to account for the grown-up audience of
the original but don't expect anything
true Ely shocking if you're familiar
with how I Carly transitioned from a
Nickelodeon sitcom to a paramont plus
Revival then you can probably expect
about the same thing with Good Burger 2
the original good burger was filmed
exclusively in California with the city
of West Cina serving as the primary
shooting location the restaurant
utilized as a standin for good burger
was a place called Peter El Loco it's
been used in other Productions over the
years including the CW Show Crazy
Ex-Girlfriend but production for the
sequel ended up happening on the
opposite side of the country even though
Ed and Dexter still side in Los Angeles
Good Burger 2 was filmed in Rhode Island
setting up shop in a former Friendly's
Restaurant in North Providence the Good
Burger 2 crew managed to recreate the
magical burger joint with the same tiled
walls Keenan Thompson even surprised the
Newport police with donuts in May 2023
during production though the shooting
decision may sound a little odd it all
makes sense when you consider that
longtime Saturday Night Live staple
Thompson is now based in New York as
Keenan Thompson and Kell Mitchell tell
that ever since the first good burger
came out they've wanted to make a sequel
but for a while nothing ever got off the
ground
as Mitchell told today in 2021 you know
we've been talking about it Kenan and I
were all about it but we're letting them
work it out contractually and all that
stuff like that but yeah me and Keenan
were down then a Keenan and Kell reunion
at the 2022 Prime Time emys gave fans
even more hope with a former even saying
on camera the sequel's coming at you but
it wasn't until March 2023 that Keenan
and Kell made the official announcement
that Good Burger 2 was indeed happening
during an appearance on The Tonight Show
welcome to gger H gibger part two
Good Burger 2 is aiming to be a
completely different thing than the
original though fans should still find
plenty to be happy about as Keenan
Thompson told today in April 2023 we
want to make a funny quirky little movie
but everybody's much much older now and
we're going to have to get past how
different everybody looks because it's
been 25 years but then if we're able to
enjoy the story along with that
hopefully we'll have balance despite
Thompson's claims it's hard to believe
that Good Burger 2 will be completely
different from the original after all
many of the same familiar jokes return
in the film's trailer plus the plot hued
pretty closely to the original with
Mondo Burger swapped out for Mega burger
and the automation from the first one
replaced by a lifelike Ed looking
Android and although Dexter appears to
have grown up in the past 26 years it
appears to be practically pretty much
exactly the same original good burger
director Brian Robbins is now the CEO
and president of Nickelodeon and a cheap
content officer at Paramount plus before
he landed those sweet gigs he once hoped
to continue the story of Dexter and Ed
in the world of Animation considering
Nickelodeon's excellent track record in
that Medium an animated good burger
would have seemingly been a perfect fit
for the network as Kell Mitchell
revealed to Business Insider in December
2022 I do have knowledge about that
Brian Robbins called me up and was like
hey let's do an animation with good
burger and I believe Chance the Rapper
was part of that too we were super
excited but then that went on hold
because of something else we're doing
with good burger which I think you might
know but that doesn't mean that an
animated continuation is completely dead
in the fryer if Good Burger 2 does well
it could wind up inspiring some more
Burger Centric material did you you know
there's actually already been a
liveaction good burger reunion in case
you forgot or you somehow missed it at
the time in 2015 Keenan Thompson and
Kell Mitchell made their way to Jimmy
Fallon's corner of late night TV for a
special surprise yes indeed there was a
full-fledged Goodburger sketch on The
Tonight Show Mitchell slipped right back
into his regular routine as Ed with
Fallon serving as his wingman Ed handled
customers with his typical peculiar
charm before hangry construction worker
Lester Oak showed up demanding a burger
it might not have been Dexter but at
least Thompson got to prise one of his
old all that characters unsurprisingly
the sketch quickly went viral so
naturally enough when it was time for
this dynamic duo to announce that Good
Burger 2 was happening they returned to
The Tonight Show to do it wait wait wait
if we're
brothers
Dad
no in Goodburger 2 there's a new burger
mobile and this one rides in style to
promote the upcoming sequel legendary
Today Show weatherman Al Roker was given
the opportunity to drive the car with
all its trademark toppings while
visiting the set of Goodburger 2 he was
even caught on camera singing we're all
dudes as he drove around the parking lot
a hot dog head I could relish that the
original burger mobile from the first
film was eventually sold off and sent to
be restored by its new owner a
businessman named Mike Johnson Johnson
just so happens to be the co-owner of
his own Burger Joint the Highpoint
Drive-In in St Louis Missouri today the
original burger mobile can be found
parked just outside the high point Good
Burger 2 actually isn't the first time
that Ed and Dexter story has been squiz
as it turns out in 1998 a book called
Good Burger to go was published it was
based on a story by Dan Schneider that
was meant to be a script for a sequel
this time around our heroes discover
that good burger has been selling Ed's
secret sauce without a license so Ed is
needed for a taste test to get it
registered atas Ed wanders off to Paris
in an effort to give a customer 18 cents
in change thankfully his best burger
buddy Dexter is also there to help get
him out of trouble did you know that a
pre Freaks and Geeks Linda calini
appeared appeared in the original good
burger she played Heather a patient in
the demented Hills psych ward that Ed
and Dexter were unceremoniously tossed
into by Mondo Burger she's the one who
tells the Ed about space aliens
convincing her to free kangaroos from a
zoo while calini delivered a memorable
performance we never learn much else
about Heather my name is Heather really
my mom's name is Heather
really no believe it or not this was
actually cardellini's feature film debut
after a few TV R she landed the part of
Heather and later appeared on the Keenan
and Kell episode Chicago Witch Trials
since then her career has really
exploded in the likes of the Scooby-Doo
movies and the Netflix Thriller series
bloodline just to name a few there
hasn't been any word yet about whether
or not we'll get to see the long awaited
reunion between Ed and Heather and good
burger too but we can certainly
[Music]
hope